a lot of these guys who push the
envelope yeah they have a target on them
right now today assassination is a
different kind of assassination you got
character assassination which is worse
sometimes than
you know some may say is worse than the
actual assassination right can i say
something about that sure
during my troubles
look you know i make light of it right i
mean i mean but those were hard years
and when you got this and they're
they're after you like that and they
have all that power you know deep down
you're dead but you're going to go down
fighting
i would frequently fight comfort late at
night when i try to fall asleep and i'd
imagine myself walking in that federal
court building and someone rescuing me
from what i was facing by walking up to
me and shooting me dead in other words
assassinate me i'd much rather have that
than what they were doing to me because
a timely assassination
it's good for your obituary and people
remember you in a more positive way but
being sent to prison for corruption when
you didn't do it
seemed to me a far worse result and so
when you call this the new kind of form
of assassination you're speaking to me
because in my own mind my preference
would have been the other then rather
than what ultimately happened now i'm
finally through it it's over and i'm
lucky i guess i'm glad i wasn't
assassinated because i believe in second
acts but you hit it right this is the
new form of assassination now this
politics of personal destruction would
use to fake criminal charges to get
people yeah so so this this almost makes
me not trust people that are career
politicians
it almost makes you think like what do
you have to do to be a career politician
not not not somebody that comes in does
the job and leaves yeah i'm just going
to come i'm going to do two terms i'm
out of here okay i did my time a one of
my rules i follow in our family is make
your money after you make your money
take care of your family and once you
can take care of your family go get back
to public service in one way or another
be a mayor be a congressman be a center
to be governor do something and then
leave right matter of fact the shorter
you're in the more i trust you
the longer you're in i trust you less
because
how many deals do you have to do behind
closed doors how much do you have to
play the game
you know in some industries tenure is a
respectable thing to do right in some
industries you think about it's a
respectable thing to do
some industries
like politics i think tenure it almost
works backwards
because you eventually are going to have
someone that's going to show you
something that they're going to try to
uh hey if you don't do this we're going
to introduce this to the we're going to
send this to new york times oh we're
going to say this about you we're going
to tell this to your wife we're going to
tell us your kids we can tell this to
your family to rooney and you're tempted
to say
[ __ ] okay what do you want me to do i
need you to do this and then they have
you forever right
that's what i mean when i say how ugly
is politics not what you went through i
really want to know how ugly
is the
job of being a politician as a career
politician
i think one of the biggest problems in
america is the fact that we have a a
permanent ruling class
made up of career politicians
lobbyists
former congressmen and senators who are
lobbyists
permanent staffers who are all over
washington i call it the political
industrial complex
it exists in washington dc it exists in
state capitals across america
presidents come and go governors come
and go
these people are there forever and when
they leave congress they're lobbyists so
there's the same people and they talk
amongst themselves and their worldview
becomes that world not where the rest of
us live the other side of the potomac
make good money five six million a year
no doubt about it it's very wealthy it's
and they protect themselves they
support themselves on the backs of
everybody else in america it is the
permanent ruling class of these career
politicians against we the people and
that's part of the realignment that's
happening in politics that's why it's
changing and so that's there's a lot of
anger understandably so
um
and it exists in both parties no one
party is
more guilty than the other they're both
very much part of that and what's
interesting too is that
um
you know the idea of term limits for
example when i first became a state rep
in 1993 i supported that
and the guy that was pushing it would
ultimately be my lieutenant governor he
was the state treasurer at the time
he pushed it just to put his name on a
bill so he could say it was for but he
didn't care to even try to pass it
there's a lot of that baloney goes on in
politics then a lot of these guys that
got elected in 1994 republicans promised
to term limits they were going to limit
themselves when they got eight years
when they got close to eight years you
know by then people forgot the promise
and they made excuses and they stayed
but i do think term limits is something
that should be seriously looked at and
you know the irony here is
our first president one of the greatest
americans of all time george washington
was all about what you just said he
served two terms and that was it he
could have been king he didn't want to
be king he could have been a three-term
president he didn't want to be
three-term president he believed like in
the old days of the roman empire that
this
cincinnatus he was a farmer he'd leave
the farm and go serve
his country and then go back to farming
until the soil that was what
washington's view was of american
politics and he set an example very
early on but over time that example is
forgotten and now you've got joe biden
as president who's been there
get this now he was 29 years old when he
was elected 30 when he was sworn in
constitutionally youngest
age he could be senator
his whole adult life has been in
washington how could he possibly really
understand the fact challenges that
everyday people face because he's been
so far away from it and just the
opposite he's a creature of that swamp
and it is a swamp it's the same old
people and it's them against us let me
let me ask you you know you know when
sometimes you say there's crooked cops
right
and then
well you know there's crooked pastors
right there's crooked preachers you know
there's crooked accountants there's
you know greedy uh capitalists hillary
whatever what i'm saying is
is the percentage of crookedness higher
in the job of a career politician than
any other occupation that's what i want
to do you know someone i'm asking yeah
exactly what i'm trying there's always a
few backgrounds always in every industry
but i wonder if the percentage of bad up
on politician is higher than other
industries what would you say to that
i'd say yes and i'd say part of it is
because a lot of the crookedness is
legal
they make the rules that benefit
themselves
remember that
the rules are unfair and wrong but they
benefit themselves and therefore they're
legal
but it's crooked because it ain't right
who's the most crooked is it the actual
uh senator representative is it the
lobbyist is it the campaign finance
person is it the person pulling the
strings is it the people donating the
money is it the koch brothers is it
george soros like who is the most
corrupt in all this well i think it's a
system i think they it's a system and a
lot of the things that you're referring
to the people you're talking about
aren't breaking laws they're just
involved in the way the system is set up
people don't like the idea of public
funding for elections okay but i wonder
if that would not be a better play where
you take money completely out of
politics
because you
they pander to their political donors
and the new politics now is you have
these grassroots contributors
and obama started this at first i
thought this was a very good new
development because he was able to
encourage people everyday people to send
small dollar checks
and raise bernie made that too
and uh aoc now right but on the
political right president trump raises a
lot of money that way and a lot of
conservative republicans do so initially
i thought this was really going to be
good because it's giving people everyday
people more of a voice but here's what
it's done it's created further division
because if you even look like you're you
have an open mind about the other side's
point of view you're going to run the
risk of losing your toners they won't
send you checks anymore so it's almost
better for you to be even more strident
against the other side and both sides
will do this because it generates
support among their donors i don't think
that's going to change anytime soon i
don't need and the reason why i don't
think it's going to change anytime soon
is the following what percentage of
career politicians what percentage of
our politicians today and i'm talking
congress senate uh governors okay take
those three what percentage of them
have been in politics more than ten
years
is majorities over ten years or majority
is less than ten years more than ten
years okay so
what percentage would more than ten
available do one or two things
change washington they're going
buddy yeah they're going to they're
either going to
they're either going to uh you know
destroy the guy's reputation or they're
going to fall in love you know or
they're going to say you have two
choices bro you have to fall in line or
we're going to do this to you which one
do and there's got to be somebody that
goes and has that conversation with them
it's a tough gig but the differentiator
these days is social media look at aoc
yeah she hasn't exactly fallen in line
with nancy pelosi or anything like that
so
you know look at tulsi gabbard you know
just social media these days is the
great equalizer so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you